so before we start I just want to
emphasize that I know that some people
have said that they watch my video with
their kids and the sadly this video is
definitely not going to be one you're
gonna watch with your kids I'm gonna
deal with an important subject I'm gonna
try to not necessarily use big words but
inevitably it will deal with some
difficult things for several years now
we have seen the subject of the
cuckolding appear in the vision of
politic especially in the right-wing
circles we've heard people talk about
this subject using it as an accusation
for people who are willing to sacrifice
their own culture in order to engage
with other in order to receive other
cultures you would say and our self
deprecating and so they'd use this term
to talk about it and it's an interesting
it's an interesting use of the term but
I also and one of the things that I've
seen is people asking me about Joseph
and in the story of the Incarnation we
see that Joseph who is promised Mary is
then all of a sudden surprised to find
that his wife is pregnant and that she
is pregnant with the Son of God and so
in a way some people have seen this as
almost a kind of divine cook holding and
you see jokes about it even in the
Middle Ages about the idea that Joseph
is somehow a kind of divine cuckold and
so we need to look at this question see
what it could mean because this notion
is a pattern of reality one which is
more pervasive than you think and also
one which actually is doesn't always
have the same meaning and can also have
a double meaning that we'll both look at
and it might also temper the way that
people try to use it in order in order
to attack their political enemies
[Music]
this is Jonathan pezzo welcome to the
symbolic world
[Music]
now in order to understand this question
we have to imagine ourselves in an
ancient world in a world of of tribes a
world of small tribes of small groups or
small clans that are surrounded by other
clans that are surrounded by more
powerful clans weaker clans we have to
be able to project ourselves in that
kind of very very primordial space and
we can imagine that in that context
whatever it is that you have in terms of
your possibilities for your future you
can understand that as your possessions
you can understand that as your land and
you can also understand it as the women
of your clan because the women are your
of your clan are the ones who will carry
your seed into the future that will
let's say permit that you continue to
exist in the future
and so all of these aspects of
potentiality you could say are something
that the clan would have had you know
like I said there's also the land and
your possessions all of these things and
so sometimes people will will be very
angry to see how in the past women were
seen as possessions but we need to
understand it symbolically in the sense
of how the the women are those that are
the vessels to bring yours to help you
to survive into the future they're the
one who will carry your children and
your children will perpetuate your your
lineage will perpetuate your story and
so you can imagine in this in this world
where you are constantly in danger of
being attacked from the outside from
other clans that are stronger than you
from other groups you know imagine that
you're just a family together with your
kids and a few families and then of a
sudden this this this strong clan will
come in and what what will they do
they'll take whatever it is you have and
that will usually include taking your
women it might include taking your women
for good or it might include just using
them on the spur of the moment and in
order to kind of cast the doubt and to
destroy your lineage you would say or
cast doubt on your lineage make you
weaker by by abusing your women
and then leaving this is has been a war
tactic from since that the dawn of time
and it is sadly still a war tactic today
where one of the tactics to destroy your
enemy is to is to abuse their women and
that way you destroy you destroy you
affect even the identity of the group
that you are attacking and now what's
really important to understand is that
that is one of the aspects of you losing
your possibilities and so you have
because one of the problems that you
have is that there's always more outside
than there is inside whatever identity
you have so you have this identity
inside and then you have all these other
things outside that are always you're
always in danger that those things are
gonna come and take what you have and
take it for themselves and therefore
destroying who you are and so this like
I said it has all kinds of connotations
and one of them is a sexual connotation
now what would you do in that context
how would you deal with that problem and
the way that you deal with the problem
is to create structures of us right to
to make your clans stronger too maybe
align yourselves with other clans that
are closer to you in terms of your
family in terms of your you know in
terms of your interests or whatever you
bind yourself together with several
people and you create a unit that is
stronger than what your unit was before
and one of the ways of doing that and
the way that seems to have been the most
effective is to also create a kind of
pyramid where you will this clan that
comes together we'll also have a head
we'll have a leader and that leader will
give your clan and I a stronger identity
will give your clan also a direction
will help organize the structure so that
you're stronger and so that you are
capable to cohere together but also more
capable to defend yourself from these
outer clans that come and get you now
you think that that would solve one of
your problems and it does solve when
your problem but then another problem
appears
and the problem is that if before your
possibilities your possessions your land
and also your wives and your daughters
would could be taken from the outside
now the specter comes that this that
your wives and your daughters and your
land and your possessions is also going
to be taken up by the chief we call it
taxes so it's like either you pay a
tribute to your enemy who attacks you
and then demands that you pay tribute to
it to them in order to stop that you
create a structure and then you end up
paying taxes so you end up paying up so
instead of paying out you pay up and so
this is an actual reality and we see it
as as old as the stories of Gilgamesh
where the people are angry against
Gilgamesh because Gilgamesh insists on
sleeping with a woman on the night of
her marriage before her husband will
have a relationship with her and the
story of this tradition this idea of
first night this tax this sexual tax
that you have to pay up to your leader
is is a story that will perpetuate
itself until until Europe you know and
you have these ideas that that
pre-christian Europe had this tradition
of first night where the chief would
have access to your wife
for the first for the first night and
then you know then you would have her
for the rest of the time and it's a way
for the chief to to to let's say to
solidify his power on you to say you are
under me and in order to show you that
you are under me I am going to take your
wife and there's not only your wife but
also your daughter so the whole image of
the king or the chief with a harem who
takes you know the the different all
takes more women than anybody because
he's above everybody else so he has this
harem of women for himself and then all
the other people that are lower than him
on the hierarchy end up you know
scrabbling and fighting to to have
access to women and so this isn't this
is a really a reality and so in this the
political sphere that we see today we we
always in you know the kind of
right-wingers they tend to want to
emphasize the idea
that you know the problem of giving up
to the outside of abandoning yourself to
the outside of being weak toward the
outside so that they take your
possibilities but you know when their
idea is to create some really really
strong authoritarian structure in order
to prevent that you don't realize that
it goes the other way as well and we
have seen examples of that in the modern
times for example a very good example
was that the tyrant
Mobutu the dictator he he named himself
Mobutu Sese Seko which in his language
one of the meanings of his of his name
is the the [ __ ] that stands above the
roof that is above all the hens and you
know and holds the hands together and so
Mobutu would it is known that Mobutu
would sleep with all the wives of his
ministers all the wives of his
counselors that if you wanted to be high
up in his hierarchy one of the things
you had to do was to give up your wife
to him for a certain amount of time in
order for him to really you know hold
his power on you and and the same thing
when he would travel around you would go
to villages it was expected that people
would offer him virgins so that he could
you know he could show his power in that
context and if you read the ancient
stories of of these kind of ancient
warlords in the tribal culture that
seemed to be the reality which is that
the the tribal warlord had access to to
to women more than everyone anybody else
and there was this first night or other
types of sexual taxes that had to be
paid up towards the toward the the chief
you know and you see it even in the
Bible you see this where when Samuel
when Samuel is telling the people that
they the people who are asking for a
king he's telling the people you know
you should be you should be wary of
having a king because if you have a king
one of the things that's going to happen
is that the king is going to take your
sons and your daughters he's gonna take
your sons to fight his Wars and he's
gonna take your daughters and add them
to his harem you know when we see that
Solomon had thousands of women
in his harem we have to understand what
that would do to a society that he he he
also he obviously got women from all
over the place but he probably got all
the best women of his own group because
he was the king and so now further
that's the first thing you need to
understand and so when you look at
stories for example in terms of the
Greek myths you see what this means you
see that this is what is going on you
have a god Zeus for example who goes
around raping women and what he's doing
is it is part of his manifesting his
power upon the earth by taking human
women impregnating them and let's say
creating this this kind of this kind of
sexual hierarchy in the world and so
even in the storytelling we see this
same problem where on the one hand you
have the you have the Greeks who tried
to unite under these gods and fight off
the barbarians who want to take their
wives but then ultimately what ends up
happening is they have to sacrifice some
of their women up to the gods in order
for them to in order for them to create
that power hierarchy and so when the
when the kind of really hard right
people and a lot of the neo-pagans as
well they tend to yearn for this ancient
world this ancient tribal world this
ancient kind of Nordic world they they
they have to understand that that is
also part of the price to pay for having
a kind of really hierarchical tribal
thing which is that you you if you do it
in order to not pay out you will end up
having to pay up and that is not
necessarily pleasant and the reason why
I think they they don't seem to see it
is because like most people even even
monarchists have this problem it's like
you meet these absolute monarchists who
you realize that the reason why their
absolute monarchist is because they
think that they're going to be the king
and the same with these kind of
neo-pagans they they seem to like this
world of power and and like strength and
all of this but they don't understand
that
they will also be subject to that and
there's very little chance that you're
the big you're gonna be the big guy with
the axe at the top of the hierarchy you
know in reality there's only one of
those up there and you tend to you tend
to end up being lower down there and
have to pay up so we have to we really
do have to to to see this and one of the
ways that you can see that this is
really something that happened in the
past is that there are moments in
history where it seems like all the
genetics point to one person you know
for example I think it's like one third
I don't know like a huge percent I may
be not one third was like a huge
percentage of people in Asia are
descendants of Genghis Khan and so you
can understand that Genghis Khan at some
point he was so powerful that him and
his sons ended up having access to all
the women and then that created this
kind of explosion in the genetic in the
genetic pool where everything kind of
comes to him and you see the same with
other there are so some northern
chieftains that also it seems to have
this genetic which points to just one
guy who was so powerful that he had
access to to all the women and so it's
really important to understand that as
we look at the symbolism of the problem
of the cuckold let's say of the one who
loses his and so you can understand it
so like you can see that the two ways
that someone would become a cuckold is
as a man is it can be both it can be
either you're a cuckold to something
which is above you can someone who's
richer someone who has more money
someone who has more prestige someone
who has more than you and the other
possibility is to also lose become a
cuckold to the outside it could be
someone who has more body someone who
has more power who's more attractive in
terms of just that that more let's say
mysterious or seductive or whatever so
you can see that those two those two
things are the reality of pretty much
all the kind of let's say cuckolding
stories that that that you can find in
terms of storytelling let's say of
course everybody who
people who experience that in their
private lives you know sometimes it's
it's more mitigated and there's there
are other personal aspects to take into
account but it's a in terms of
storytelling we can also we can see that
these are the two extremes that happen
and so the problem is how do you deal
with that
right because this is just an aspect of
reality you cannot completely take
sexuality out of the way that
hierarchies lay themselves out you just
cannot so you have to deal with it and
so what it seems is that the story of
Christianity it seems like it ends up
being a way to solve the problem of this
couple problem and how does it do that
well so imagine that you have a king
who's taking your women or a God who's
taking your women who's actually having
relationships with them and it seems
like what what happens is Christian is
that we push that higher it's like you
lift up this notion of a God having a
relationship with a person to the
highest possible and so we don't say
that an angel had a relationship with a
woman like for example one of the
traditions in Genesis and that creates
these monsters we say that is know it is
God himself it is the highest highest
possible thing in the hierarchy now that
is one of the aspects so you push it way
way way way way way way way up and then
which you then do is you declare that
the woman who is giving birth then
didn't have sex with God and this is
really important to understand this is
really the tradition of the Christian
Church we say that the mother God is a
perpetual virgin
now Protestants have mitigated that in
in in I don't totally understand why
that they that they want to emphasize
the fact that she wasn't but the
traditional view that Catholic and the
Orthodox view is that the mother God is
a perpetual virgin that she remained a
virgin before she was pregnant I while
she was giving birth and after she was
pregnant now you can say I don't
understand it in terms of biology it
doesn't matter
try to understand it in terms of the
story so you push it up you push up into
the extreme and then you bring down to
the extreme where this this sacrifice
ends up being one which in which the the
woman remains a virgin and remains a
perpetual virgin and so this to me it
ends up seems to end up being the
solution to the cuckolding problem you
create this extreme thing and it becomes
the let's say the ultimate way in which
reality is solved the problem of the
hierarchy gets solved and that gives it
gives Christ but it also creates a world
in which you were going to see as
Christianity develops this notion that
you need to pay attacks a sexual tax up
towards the aristocrat is going to
slowly go away we see that in the early
Middle Ages already this idea of first
Knight had become it seems like it had
become a tax that you would pay that you
wouldn't actually you know the
aristocrat wouldn't actually have a
relationship with your wife and it seems
like that also completely went away at
some point it was not none of that was
expected even in terms of it kind of
symbolic giving up towards your towards
your leader um and what's fascinating
about that is that then you it seems
like in Christianity what's going to
also happen is that in order to kind of
create a to continue to emphasize this
issue we're then going to have a culture
of virginity in a certain caste of the
culture and so certain people will give
themselves up to God in a in a in a
sexual language and will remain virgins
in order to let's say in order to enact
this pattern and within that the society
will be fruitful the society will be
will be fruitful and will also and so a
lot of people don't you know they
struggle with the idea of you know how
can you have monastics is somehow
counterintuitive because you think that
you have
monasteries and you think how can if you
encourage monasteries and then it's it's
against the idea of perpetuating your
your lineage like it's somehow
anti-human to do that to have
monasteries but now that you understand
it in this manner not if you understand
it in the manner of enacting a narrative
which which sets the bit the barrier so
that society in the middle can be
fruitful and so that it doesn't have to
be constantly paying up towards the the
emperor but then you can also defend
yourself towards losing your
possibilities to the outside so that
seems to have been a it seems to have
been played out this way it also seems
that this wasn't the first time that
there was an attempt to solve this
problem to solve the problem of the
relationship between the inside and the
outside the capacity to create something
which is higher than the group are
higher than the clan in order to cohere
the clan in an even stronger way so we
see other stories where there is this
strange relationship with a foreign
agent or another agent where cuckolding
is actually part of the very origin of a
people or the very origin of a great
leader for example in the legend of
Alexander we see an attempt to solve
this problem in the Alexander romance
Alexander is not the son of Philip of
Macedon but is rather the son of the
Egyptian pharaoh nicked a Naboo this
Pharaoh comes to the court of Philip
pretending to be an Egyptian magician or
an Egyptian priest and in that guise he
then pretends to be the god Eman and as
the god Eman he seduces Alexander's
mother Olympia and that is how Alexander
is born so you can see there's a very
complicated series of events happening
here in this attempt to make Alexander
the son of nicked an oboe we can see how
all the things I've been telling you are
in that version on the one hand
Alexander is visibly the kid the son of
Philip of Macedon
invisibly or in another manner he's also
the son of this foreign king in the same
way he is also in a strange way of
bringing everything together he also
ends up being the son of this God Ammon
who is associated with Zeus himself and
so you see the bringing together of this
foreign God Ammon with Zeus with this
foreign king and this also foreign
priests as a kind of spiritual authority
and so you can see in this a whole true
of factors that are brought together in
order to try to solve the problem of
inside and outside in the attempt to
make Alexander a greater figure a figure
that can unite more people under his
identity and not just the little country
of Macedon if you look at all the
elements in the story of King Arthur for
example you will see that it is almost
all the same in the story of King Arthur
Uther Pendragon has himself disguised
that as grains husband by the sorcerer
Merlin and in that guise that is how
Arthur is born and so you can see that
there is this [ __ ] holding right there
at the origin of King Arthur who was
going to be the one that was able to
unite all of England together a very
strange detail in this story is that in
the desire to join the inside and the
outside some of the extreme symbolism
will even be used so in the story of
Alexander the Great for example there
are some versions where this Pharaoh
Nick Tana Bowe who pretends to be a
priest or a magician is described as
having dragon-like qualities and in the
story of King Arthur we also see that
although now it's not ether who is a
dragon but rather Merlin who helps in
this whole story is also the son of a
dragon and so all of these are attempts
to join the extreme outside with the
highest thing to try to create a figure
that it has you know indefinite
possibility and can
you night you know further and further
out into the world different people's we
see also this this in the Bible as well
in the story of Moses we see that a
Moses was an Israelite who was raised by
the Egyptians here we kind of see it as
the opposite where he was a foreign
agent who was being raised by the
Egyptian king himself so we can see
people trying to play with this problem
in different ways even in the story of
Abraham who is the founder of the Jewish
people
there is also an ambiguity which is set
up because Abraham's wife was taken by
the Pharaoh for a certain amount of time
and so it's actually left ambiguous who
exactly is the father of Isaac although
we we traditionally tend to think that
it's Abraham the Bible and the story
wants to cast a little bit of a doubt in
the story of who is actually the father
of Isaac so that you ultimately can
understand how it is also a trying to
bring together these different elements
into one and even in the story of Christ
we can see how strangely enough in the
Christian version of the story we see
that Christ is the very son of the
creator whereas in the Jewish version of
the story
Christ is seen as the result of Mary
being raped by a Roman soldier and so if
you put those two traditions together
you have this ultimate kind of
contradiction this ultimate moment where
in all the in his entourage Christ would
have been seen as the result of a rape
of the Roman soldier and you can
understand that that is also how the
Jews would understand the in a way the
conversion of Rome to Christianity while
on the other hand Christ is also seen as
the very son of God and the son of a
virgin and so you can understand you can
see how there really is a desire to work
out this problem and it is not at all a
simple question if we want to create a
story which is which can outlast the
others the other interesting aspect is
of course a lot of people will say that
in the story you see Joseph and Mary
Joseph is this cuckold of God but that
Christianity itself is a cuckold
religion because it is a foreign
religion that was taken up by the Roman
Empire and so it was a you know it's a
Jewish religion that was taken by the
Roman Empire and by doing that the the
Roman Empire weakened itself and you
know you have this this hope this
strange idea that it was somehow the
cause of the the fall of the Roman
Empire you see that in kind of
enlightenment thinking that that the
fact that Rome became Christian was the
cause of it sound father this is of
course absolutely nonsense because the
more Christian part of the Empire which
was not Rome which was in fact
Constantinople continued on for a
thousand years it's not bad a thousand
years is not bad for something to
continue on and so the the brightness of
Constantinople seems to contradict the
idea that Christianity is the cause of
the fall of the Roman Empire because in
fact a Rome was the more pagan of the
two and the Senators in Rome continued
to be pagan for a very long time even
after the conversion of of Christianity
there was a large tension in Rome
between Christians and pagans because
the elite in Rome continued to be pagan
so we have to deal with this accusation
we have to deal with this idea or this
problem of why is it that the Roman
Empire would do such a thing and I think
that this is really similar to what I
talked about in terms of Mary and Joseph
I think that what happened is a very
similar thing now let me try to explain
it to you the the problem is that if you
just pretend like this pattern isn't
real like one of the patterns which is
that that which is outside of you is
bigger than you and that's just the
reality on the edges your edges can be
stretched out really indefinitely and
one of the problems that happen in the
Roman Empire is that they had reached so
big that all of a sudden the place in
which they had reached you know it's
like if you build a row if you build
roads out in order to invade all these
countries those roads are
there once you get a little weaker those
connections are all there for the people
you invade it to come back and swamp you
you know that's something that people
don't tend to realize that it's a
reality not just in Roman times but it
also it is also a modern reality which
is that you know things roads don't just
go one way you have to be careful in
when you extend yourself too far you
know and so Rome was surrounded by these
these barbarian groups the Germans
you know all these these kind of
dramatic groups but also the Citians and
and you know even on their East and
front with the Persians and all of these
different empires and they were starting
to to break apart in the third century
crisis we can see this problem you know
it looks like the Emperor's gonna gonna
break apart and you have all these
barbarian generals that are vetting for
power and are trying to take pieces of
Rome for themselves and so here it is
this massive massive problem now how do
you deal with it because the idea of
just asserting yourself and asserting
your identity and coming back to your
identity it solved the problem in the
short term but it isn't a it isn't a a
total solution to the problem of the
duality of inside and outside it isn't
it it isn't a complete solution you know
because that reality is just the way the
world works and we have to find a way to
solve the problem in terms of narrative
and so it seems like in terms of
understanding the narrative wrong did
what the Christians story is itself I
often tell you that the Christians story
is a changing of death into glory a
changing of the crown of thorns into a
crown of glory all of this is the way
that Christianity the story of
Christianity is happening so we have to
understand to understand this properly
we also have to understand that for the
first three centuries of the story of
Christianity
Christianity's were the scapegoats
themselves that Nero had identified them
as those that wanted to destroy Rome and
so they were persecuted as this
religious group they were you know the
they were they were full of slaves and
women
it wasn't the elite of the society and
they were scapegoats and there were also
this foreign religion which refused to
integrate into the kind of syncretic
deal that the Romans had been making in
terms of their in terms of their
religious ideas until now they had been
accepting all the different gods and
identifying them with their gods and so
you had these weird sand credit gods
that the Romans started to engage with
where they were a mix of Egyptian and
Roman gods mix of Greek Roman pagan gods
you know when they talk about the
northern people they they tried to
identify their gods and say that they
worship Mars you know and so they had
this weird syncretic system and there
was this one group that refused to
participate there were two there were
the Jews and the Christians but the
Christians were particularly heinous
because you know the Jews at least were
completely separate the Christians were
Romans still kind of converting Romans
but also at the same time they they had
been considered scapegoats by by the
Roman state from the very very early
stages right even in the time of the
Apostles already the Christians were
considered the scapegoats in the
destruction of Rome right and so you see
in the narrative we're still saying that
Christians are the reason for the
destruction of Rome but we see the
narrative the Christians were the
scapegoat Christ with the scapegoat all
of this is going on and also the
scapegoat as this foreign thing that is
not part of your your identity all of
this is kind of coming together and so
in their moment of crisis as Rome was
being surrounded by everything it seems
like what they did was take this thing
which was in a way was the lowest thing
in their society and flip it up so that
it would become a crown so that it would
be in a way above the Roman state and
the deal when you do that is that you
solve the problem of the cuckold -
because you take the foreign thing and
you don't
you put it above you like completely
above you so high up that just like this
idea of having God and Mary God being so
high and and the mother of God remaining
a virgin you take this foreign this
whole foreign question of the scapegoat
of the of the the foreign religion all
of this and you and you flip it up so
that it becomes the glory of Rome and so
in that deal what ends up happening is
that Rome remains Rome and this is
something which is hilarious because
everybody hates that now everybody hates
the fact that Christianity is Roman
you know Protestants hate it the the
even the neo-pagans hate that all the
modern people hate everybody hates
Constantine you know he's an enemy
number one despite the fact that
Constantine is one of the key figures in
the very this very flip of changing the
scapegoat into a into the highest thing
and so the deal ends up being that Rome
can remain Rome the Emperor can remain a
Roman Emperor the forms of Rome can
remain Roman the architecture the art
everything remains Roman Christ himself
ends up being dressed as a Roman senator
ends up being dressed as a as a as a
Roman Emperor because he he is above and
as he felt as this thing which is
completely above the system filters in
it actually doesn't destroy the system
it ends up being at the secret root or
the secret cause of this whole thing and
so they've done it's like as if they've
done the whole solve the problem of the
cuckold solved also the problem of the
foreigner once and for all because that
problem doesn't go away and it's
interesting to see that and it's
interesting to see that it seems also
then that Christianity seems to
something similar seems to happen with
Christianity in the different places
where it manifests itself and so if you
look at the earliest earliest forms of
Christianity you'll have EcoP ins who
convert to Christianity and they have an
Ethiopian Christianity you have
Armenians who convert to Christianity
and they have an
me nyan Christianity and so we are able
to then also be in communion without
denying the particularity of the
different peoples and so you one of the
things that happens in Christianity is
ideally this unity and multiplicity that
is the respect for the different
identities but also the capacity to be
in communion nonetheless and so it
doesn't it's not supposed to and it has
not until very recently in the modern
world been just this kind of chaos of
mixture and and it's this idea that we
have to destroy all identity this is
really a modern a modern invention but
rather it was a kind of symphonic vision
where you could be a still be a Northman
you could still be a ETOP and you could
still be armenian you could still have
your national identity and nonetheless
be in communion with people from other
groups because of this crown which was
above and which permitted the
multiplicity to exist within the unity
and so it seems like and so in the both
sense in in the proper sense in terms of
the notion of the of the the cuckold in
terms of the problem of that which is
above taking from below we see how
christianity solved it in the story of
mary and joseph and it also seems like
christian ii christianity solved the
problem of the problem of the influence
of the outside how to deal with the fact
that the outside is bigger than you
without you either
just stifling yourself in this this this
kind of doing out taking out the ax and
just started chopping everybody's heads
out that is outside of your identity or
nor letting yourself be completely
swallowed up by this flood that comes
from the outside so it feels like
christianity has found a balance between
the extremes by creating this flip and
so this is something that I've just been
exploring in terms of my thinking i've
been kind of provoked by it by seeing
this question of cuckolding appear you
know all more and more in on the
internet and in my comment section and
even people people writing me to ask me
questions about that so hopefully it
would be the beginning of a discussion
I'm looking forward to seeing what some
of you are gonna say in the comment
section I get a feeling that part of the
comment section is going to degenerate
into absolute madness but I'll try to
pay attention to the quality comment and
see if we can push this discussion
further and if some interesting things
come out I might make another video on
the subject once again so guys thank you
for watching and I will see you soon I
hope you enjoyed this episode of the
symbolic world don't forget to check out
my events page on my website the
symbolic WorldCom where you will see
that I will be in Boston in February and
the soon I will be posting also dates
for an event that I'll be doing in
Seattle and also I will be in
Connecticut near Hartford Connecticut in
June Seattle in May so please stay tuned
to that because I love to meet you guys
in person don't forget to subscribe to
the clips channel they're doing a great
job at pulling out all the nuggets from
my old conversations I'll put a link to
that in the description and you know
we're going to make a huge change this
year I'm going to change the website
into a multi-user blog and I'm hoping to
make it the primal source for symbolic
thinking in terms of popular culture in
terms of traditional ideas religious
stories help you understand the
scripture the liturgy but also
interpretations of movies and book
reviews so that will be happening this
year and it is all thanks to people
supporting me through my website through
patreon or a subscribe star I really
appreciate it
it's really giving me wings and is
opening up the world to the symbolic
thinking so thanks a lot and I talk to
everybody very soon